do you want to see what the world is
really like
yes my name is Emma Stone I'm playing
Bella Baxter in the film poor
things this is Bella she's Mi PR she's
understanding what it is to be a member
of society good evening the more
autonomous she becomes the more
challenged these men seem to be by it
it's a very very funny
film why do people not just do this all
the
[Music]
time we must experience everything Bella
this makes us
[Applause]
hope I wanted to play Bella because it
felt like acceptance of what it is to be
a woman to be free to be scared and
Brave Bella why I keep it in my mouth if
it is revolting
I must go punch that
[Music]
baby